j'ai froid que se passe-t-il ce sont les
premiers mots écrits par un homme mort
enfin c'est ce qu'avait déclaré les
médecins appelés à son chevet afin
d’accorder par deux fois le permis
d'inhumer curieusement c'est à son
croque-mort que Michel Delépine doit
être toujours en vie aujourd'hui rousan
Ava vicians ça va mieux vous souvenez un
peu de ce qui s'est passé
ce qui s'est passé mercredi dernier
Michel Delepine un coiffeur de 33 ans et
découvert inanimé au piétons lit par son
père qui alerte aussitôt le médecin de
famille
et après j'en mets un confirmer l'amour
de mon fils plus lors d'une clôture les
jolies vides et alors étant tout à fait
froid là on a déchaîné il a fait donc
appelé les pompes funèdes en attendant
tout à fait mouillant froid blanc mais
tout à fait bouillant aucune j'ai été
cadavérique
tout de suite j'ai fait des massage
cardiaque massage cardiaque qui ne
ranime pas Michel Delepine à l'hôpital
où on l'emmène l'électrocardiogramme et
l'encéphalogramme confirme la mort
clinique on s'apprête à faire la
toilette funèbre lorsque à nouveau un
signe de vie se manifeste on place alors
le malade sous oxygène au nom de
doucement sa température et le miracle
se reproduit après plusieurs heures de
coma prolongées Michel Delepine renaît
littéralement à la vie
je ne sais pas ce que ça vous fait à
vous mais moi ça me fait franchement
froid dans le dos
[Musique]